louder with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter unha-3 billion
videos were demonetized on August 29th
2016 the platform that controlled the
machines YouTube net sent two computers
back through time their mission was to
destroy the mug club of the free-speech
resistance and to watch late-night
comedy die a slow painful death
[Music]
the first computer was programmed to
separate this channel from its
subscribers even disabling notifications
it failed the second was sent to ban an
event at the University of Michigan on
October 25th as before the free speech
resistance was able to send a lone
warrior an entertainer to preserve the
event a protector was just a question of
which one arrived first
come with me if you want to laugh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's the sound of the weekend coming
that's the Thursday live stream and we
have in third chair today actually that
you couldn't tell that he was dancing
because his dance is the equivalent to
restless leg syndrome Nick DeCarlo
are you talking about 1/8 black your one
sestri calm said something like that I'm
serious Nick dip calm and your twitter
as long as they allow you as where is at
Kevin Meany no at Nick DiPaolo
happy at Nick DiPaolo and we have
quarter black of course producing at
Gerald Morgan G Morgan Jr what's the one
of the day have bialy black chicken
sorry the races and we have Ted Cruz in
studio that this is his lead him all
right before I move on with that listen
my question today we're I was gonna get
to Cavanaugh hearings and a rebuttal of
the gala Tina over there at Vox
as a society we kind of a give and take
values right they define us Compassion's
important Mercy's important or do you
think the scales into tip though toward
justice presuming innocence empathy
versus justice how do you navigate the
balancing act comment below I'll give
you my answer later are you feeling good
there and this was terrific
I think it's the boom I thought you had
a real studio I didn't know it was a
condo I'm actually feeling good about
mine now listen no this is actually
beautiful you just said you know you're
to run into it the cab driver on the way
here right are we not supposed to talk
about that because of you know the the
the Terrorism issue oh no no it was fun
he he just spoke I blamed the Hyatt they
called Hyatt Place Dallas /tao what is
it
the colony to colony yeah that's the
name of the town of the colony yeah
there's also a white said I'm from the
Boston and you're from the Cleveland
right yeah maybe
area doc Cleveland in Cleveland so I you
know I show him and his broken English I
show him the address he pulls away four
minutes into the ride he hands me this
device it wasn't a black it was a hybrid
of a blackberry to pay phone right he
built that his candle it is yes sim
o'clock boy he got together and made it
happen he asked me to he asked me to
type in the address of the you know 5200
memorial whatever I'm comic talker yeah
I go I don't know how to work this why
am i doing your job then he get mad he
pulled over now I got the right now I've
the king of Nigeria staring at me with
these dead
they're back at him and then I said
let's use my Waze app so I burnt up all
my battery getting us to the rock it
took me to the cave what's your name
baby Hutchinson what's it
hey Bailey Hutchinson I'm leaving you
out in this one all I get is a text from
Nick right before you get to you I am
particularly agitated right now well
okay well let's look so good I find out
the story and I feel bad I'm sorry well
it said hi it I thought was a real Hyatt
this is like Alec went to N on steroids
it's very nice but I'm glad you got here
safely everyone glad to have you here I
couldn't be happier leading the news of
course the White House finds a no
support and just found out in the FBI
report for sexual assault claims against
Brett Kavanaugh let's come to the New
York Times so you know it's real but
with this additional information the
White House is fully confident the
Senate will vote to confirm judge
Kavanaugh to the Supreme Court and it
looks like we're actually we will not be
seeing a confirmation vote on Saturday
the more information that comes out here
the truth or less credible Ford's story
sounds people don't like to hear that if
the left had had their way but it'd be a
very different country now then can you
identify the man Tom would you stand up
please would you catch this please well
then good enough for me Oh probably
guilty I rest my case i sentence you to
wait wait mr. Fenton raped a girl
I didn't are you sure this is the man
who raped you that settles it guilty as
sin wait wait no mr. Fitch no no I
wouldn't even marry tonight you don't
even work you know this Tom do you mean
to tell me that you're questioning a
survivor
bunch of baloney and you know it don't I
deserve a fair trial
it's supposed to be innocent to prove
them guilty right black lives matter too
now you know yes one moment in time that
may have been true but now we have to
believe all women period now you're
saying this man raped you yes he does
Clarence Thomas that sound about right
yeah a little bit of a different hero
these days Atticus Finch did you really
kill Mockingbird I did why would you
question that I was I never did well I
was forced to a gun point I never read
any of the American classics look at
drawing up I realize that well that's
good you a Canuck I didn't read any
Canadian classics either I did we spend
an entire semester White House the Ken
Dryden story you spend a semester on
Karla Homolka show no it's the real one
yeah it's a horrible place Canada and
our histories very uninteresting we
spent a half a year learning about how
Canada burned down the White House and
it wasn't even a country with a column
that's just because you don't select
your friends to burn down your crap
that's your biggest accomplishment not
really all that much of an
accomplishment when I think about it
speaking of the law police are now
warning citizens about drunken Birds
this comes from the home the Duluth
Tribune chief tied to car I guess is his
name wrote that the department received
calls about birds that appeared to be
under the influence flying into windows
cars and acting confused better be fair
the main burden question is demanding a
hearing to clear his good name so he
does seem as though yeah doing pretty
well for himself
look hashtag not all pigeons okay have
you ever seen the drunken animal though
they are absolutely hilarious like when
they bite into like an apple that's been
fermented on the ground or something
like that that's falling off like I've
seen a drunken deer oh you mean
accidentally party drinking beer until
the animal can't walk you know nothing
like I think bears do that on purpose
bears enjoy the
really yeah can anyone confirm that I
don't know MIT we need community idea I
went to school up a man I should know
some about that was too drunk type syrup
the bears and you drive many times but
never made it were hauled to the forest
yes and then the bear took they took
part in the devil's triangle apparently
after too much meat which is a sexual
assault of an internationally this
German parents forgot their
five-year-old at an airport in Germany
in case you're wondering
police said of other explained officers
that the family had driven home in
separate cars and each believed that the
child was with the other parent so
spurred interest of course in a German
remake of the popular holiday classic I
leaned through the house set and that's
going to do pretty well at the box
office if you rather not originally
though it doesn't seem like the Germans
are planned it seems like these are
these the same parents that you're just
supposed to trust and be like you can't
tell me how to raise my kid is that the
kind of parents like the university suck
in my opinion yeah sort of like
Bostonian parents they're trying to work
me into this sketch I well I use this a
medikit here and let the regulars get
these shots in I can't wait in this dump
I mean I don't worry [ __ ] the game is
rigged you didn't know that but but
you're right that's very unoriginal a
one parent thought the other one yeah
that's the one they were trying to why
my parents used one they left me these
large Julie's right your mom had you
back in the back when I was a kid I
referenced it because they were sure I
know but you think of how expensive the
architecture was back then oh yeah I
never does like that was one big giant
commercial for the Orange Julius
worse you're not gonna build an Orange
Julius these days have you seen
originally it turned into a drive-in
theater where I was raised actually the
one Orange Julius yeah because then I
was going to play with it and drive and
see that big but no well it was it was
like it was it became the concession
stand for the driver because they wanted
everyone to see it from the road it's
very expensive real estate here's a
drive-in theater in downtown Detroit did
you know this really yeah last time I
was there's a downtown Detroit drive-in
theater yeah and went to the midnight
showing I have three night forms oh my
and no hubcaps but speaking which I just
watched Midnight Run last night when I
was secular you ever see that within
your own about 150 times yes did you
make fan love it
Midnight Run yeah I've not seen it in at
least a decade I've never seen what are
you Canadian yeah borderline yeah
I highly recommend as a great vinick's
do it have you ever seen it no no I've
never seen with DeNiro its back its back
when De Niro was still funny before he
became comedy De Niro ah you know after
before like Meet the Parents that was
just De Niro was kind of in that she's
kind of a good joke probe and I watched
last week and I was reminded how awful
truly awful Al Pacino is in heat
[Laughter]
recently no he's so bad you haven't did
you remember how bad he when he was
starting to get big right he's all too
big he there's a scene literally he's
talking I come black guy goes you know
man I think it killed for telling you
that stuff man he goes you could get
killed walking your dog E he overdid his
Pitino is he doing the Ed Sullivan
children the gun this is my device here
Al Pacino in Serpico Glengarry Glen Ross
you know egg - yeah yeah he you know
Jack Lemmon just just acted circles
around him and that oh yeah that was
great all the way around though for me
yeah yeah what a great love it we're
gonna have it man on the show soon I
would say if you have to pick someone
overall if you look at a span of the
career probably the greatest actor ever
you have to put Jack Lemmon in there I
go with Larry Storch from F Troop used
to be a space you go back to some like
it hot right you go back early Jack
Lemmon and he was just as good at that
as it was in in Clanker there Glen Ross
breaking your heart yeah he did you know
what I'm a head of John Ritter
I mean though he was hilarious in
Three's Company
turning to the midterm elections because
we have Ted Cruz coming up everybody Ted
Cruz gray suit is gonna be thrilled to
be here oh yes then Ben and Jerry needs
names for flavors for the seven
up-and-coming progressive candidates
this is from his Twitter yo Internet so
you know he's hip yeah we need your help
to come up with seven amazing flavors
for seven amazing up-and-coming
progressives
who could be headed to Congress in
November so of course Ben is a noted
Bernie Sanders supporter and with the
recent rise of Democratic socialists to
the pop culture we actually have a list
of their top suggestions so far which
brings us to this week's 7 + 1 they
always forget the one so Nick are you
gonna you want to help us out here
you'll be able to read any of these or
do you need to put on that those
spectacles I can read them this is just
the perfect distance so top Ben and
Jerry's progressive flavors that they
actually even been taking the polls
needs been apena
number 7 Venezuelan bread line pudding
that's right up there they're gonna be
happy about that number 6
starvation genocide July no I don't
think I'd be the first one that I would
go for let's have a NIC give us number 5
Alexandria Acacio it should say cooked
Alcott konatess that's the dad joke
that's what I wanted to convey Owen with
bones heads all right look see I like it
with nuts listen but reading that ok I
should have looked at the stuff before
like you said that reads konatess I'm so
you know very Hispanic alright well
let's make it up to you read you can
read number 4 final solution sherbet
good number three kind of a string a
little bit single-parent pee-can did ya
think I'm this nice sort of odd gee
shucks Canadian and you come in and
break walls and then now I have you
Bibles I haven't even touched you today
ah number two you want to give us number
two there uh Nick strawberry killing
fields forever backseat thousand
cooperative number one actually the
number one flavor of as far as zyklon-b
MIT that's pretty popular and the plus
one because it's kind of unrelated to
plus one finally the seven plus one top
ten in Jerry's flavors Jerry Garcia or
else all three hundred percent inflation
rate seven plus one everybody
it was one confusion where it was
because when you read it you're thinking
Cortez yeah
not Kohn exactly that's what just
happened on there that's that drop out
in eighth grade I'm glad we went back
over that oh how are you I'll finally
another story before we have to get to
the TCU follow but we talked about the
tension you follow up in a recent change
my mind and the the mental counselling
required thereafter along with a
rebuttal devoxx
before that these academics submitted a
hoax paper about dog rate just to peru
lien it'll be published in a
peer-reviewed journal and it was
published in a peer-reviewed journal so
here's a clip from the peer thank you
for your contribution to gender place
and culture and I hope to be seeing your
manuscript in print people think this is
that's that's really actually got
published and we always have wondered
this the peer review journals yeah well
this isn't the first one that they've
gotten published you know it's not six
or seven other multiple ones yeah they
vary they're all very silly yeah almost
as silly as contests at first the story
seems completely unbelievable until you
realize have actually low the standards
are what counts as evidence in 2018 I
think particularly in recent weeks like
the latest smear against Cavanaugh used
by more recently the most recent we
heard the reason one oh yeah the one
used by CNN is use this as evidence yeah
[Music]
from her lips to Lady Justice is the
longest four minutes of nicked Apollo's
life please Nick dip calm and to people
who if I were to still really really
want to go something you know what I've
never actually seen you live in the last
row Nia don't ruin your image of me a
hump would be a nick in nor McDonald if
you can see two people by the way it my
favorite comic is he really a favorite
by the way if you're if you're
subscribed to the notification bail
because subscriptions don't mean
anything apparently and YouTube anymore
join mug clubs where you at The Daily
Show for nine dollars annually
sixty-nine students veterans active
military or follow on the iTunes
Instagram lotto with Crowder and it'll
be a good time we did the change my mind
at TCU this Monday yeah and it was one
of the biggest ones that we have ever
done and we're very grateful accept
immediately afterward
the reaction on you it was somewhat
predictable yeah and uh let's just read
some of the reactions here that you see
please let me for those who didn't see
the video we sat down rape culture
azimuth changed my mind that's pretty
basic stuff not rape is a myth rape
culture is a myth the idea that a
society encourages perpetuates or
tolerates rape and anyone was willing to
anyone who was willing to sit down could
change my mind in a public space in a
public space away
TCU officially reacted on Twitter so
here's one tweet from this is from TCU
Nick today steven crowder chose to
challenge our students on a public
sidewalk in front of the university
while the Constitution gives him the
right to express his views the
sentiments he expressed do not align
with TCU's values I'll answer this
question go ahead I was gonna say you're
asking a legitimate question yes well
actually even making a statement here's
something one step further a rape
culture is a myth changed my mind where
I'm saying we don't live in a rape
culture particularly on campus right
throat me wrong we disagree with Stevens
view right so what's the culture on the
TCU Campbell just exactly just the words
rape culture yeah just you get that's it
you're guilty you're your wife you
outlaw rape culture if they're
disagreeing with me they say we disagree
when Steven says there's no when Steven
says there's no rape culture on TCU we
disagree we disavow that point of view
all right TC you be my guest
here's whether his views adversely
affected many members of our campus
community to health and safety of the
Horned Frog families of the utmost
importance and we encourage individuals
to contact campus resources for sport
another tweet from them in support of
survivors of sexual assault at TCU SGA
set up in front of the founder statute
today to promote the it's on us campaign
is TCU does not follow steven crowder on
twitter i'm really glad they made the
point to say that university feels now
that the public sidewalk we do not
follow steven crowder on twitter
boom our mission is to foster academic
social and personal development for all
members of the campus community weather
and race class ethnic gender sexual
orientation ability or veteran status
what does that have to do with any
at this point I think that's the first
time I've ever heard veteran's status
use like that like it's a complaining
group of people that are gonna express a
differing point of view that other
normal people in this case they mean
veterans of house parties especially
their job is to create an academic
social environment so that people can
learn unless you have a different point
of view right a legitimate different
point of view and you're not out there
saying rape is cool and holding up signs
you're saying hey guys let's have a
conversation about rape culture what are
you thinking they're like oh my gosh to
grow this sort of freaking out yeah
girls start freaking out when she
realized that she had no argument yet
freaking out it the words let's have a
conversation right yeah yeah that's why
they start freaking yeah well you don't
have to get to the end of it no you
don't think at the end of it all what
happened is if you go watch this video
and Nick's very busy so I know he hasn't
seen the video I she goes starts talking
about Brett Kavanaugh and I go I don't
you know the lefty with a great sense of
who's Christine forward and she starts
screaming at me and so then finally go
okay can I can I speak and I said well
listen if we're talking about dr.
Christine for dinner allegations of
bedspread cab and I start going Bing
Bing Bing Bing and she just goes okay
well so maybe you know these things and
she literally just heard screaming at
the cops yeah the second you can see the
moment in her eyes this second she
realizes that she wasn't entirely
correct here that's right there's a
letter to the students and faculty from
someone named Catherine toll ok Tito the
KT tall Center by your uber driver
exactly yeah TCU's Vice Chancellor I
guess for Student Affairs she sent this
out an email a letter maybe was maybe
was it was it was rubber stamp I have no
idea could have been wax stamped at this
point who knows how it would adjust your
grandeur she wrote yesterday was an
interesting and difficult day for a
campus community many watched and some
participated as steven crowder
self-proclaimed conservative political
commentator acting queen engaged
passerby
where's bob who are these people
i don't know apparently she's like that
the dickens play cut and the filming of
his podcast mr. Crider makes is living
by posting posing a divisive statement
to a group off in colorado his method of
operations to garner reaction from
students which he
turn makes fun of while filming for his
show here a couple of facts about
yesterday's event oh that's a lie this
we're at the fourth this is the letter
after four tweets in it gets better
it treating you like you're Brett
Kavanaugh number one
TCU did not host nor did any group host
mr. Crowder I can confirm number two he
positioned himself on a public sidewalk
on a public street see why number one
number three his language and ideas
while offensive are protected by the
United States Constitution this needed
further explanation you imagine can you
effing imagine I cannot show nice job
these mother spoke too soon alright
what's offensive oh it's like there's no
rape culture TCU is saying they have a
right that's the only thing they could
be mad about all they do have you seen
the football team on a Saturday night
before that though Nick I'm just saying
he's very diverse I'm not yes a lot of
white defensive backs I was pointing out
how dare you
here's there was actually from Fort
Worth weekly Steven Crowder's a rape
culture apologist this will happen
within one day live in mind of the video
here's another reaction conversations
without consent was another article
seemed credit discussion of rape culture
and TCU's sidewalk it's not even their
sidewalk socialists have no concept of
personal property now or public property
what do you think it's not your sidewalk
that I would prefer that's my sidewalk
we don't give a rat's ass Bernie it's
about your sidewalk disagree what do you
think is happening here it's
irresponsible to subject the public to
this kind of highly sensitive topic
without their consent so this is how we
get into it right consent I sat down
with a sign you see the logic here it is
your you can't put that sign up there
expressing an opinion without consent
you don't they don't understand consent
you don't have to consent to my opinion
mmm-hmm just like it doesn't mean it's a
refusal of your consent if someone says
hey gorgeous
and you say don't call me gorgeous
that's not rape no doesn't count and the
signs not that big
no it's really small signs like I'm not
gonna lie it's really horrible sign this
was my favorite
tweet was actually someone sitting there
just by the sidewalk that behold how
much money would it take for alumni like
myself to privatize the sidewalk all of
a sudden they're big fans of
privatization oh yeah yeah so scumbags
like steven crowder can't use her
university as a backdrop for bigotry
Nick when's the last time you performed
in a college uh this girl we're in bunk
beds he's about five ten to sixteen
Lewiston Maine this is the puppetry of
the penis tour I performed horrible
that's a good question I'd say four
years ago I did like a collagen Connect
not even three years ago in Connecticut
if I'd say the name Ian you know it and
it was the University of Connecticut was
it couldn't resist I want to say Trinity
um and then afterwards you said no more
no that was actually decent really yeah
I stopped doing colleges four years into
my career which was 1991 I was booked at
the universe at Clark University in
Massachusetts yeah I can imagine and
I've made some crack about a Middle
Eastern guy trying to find my dipstick
and oil whatever him as one day oh my
god like a guy because what he gonna
talk about rape next and so I ripped off
like a love and rape joke and I actually
had to leave one of the only shows like
30 years I actually did get off the
stage about 12 minutes sir did they
actually force you to leave they you
know they were booing and hissing and
they wouldn't let me get word I mean I
wish I had this I was like ahead of the
curve it's what's going on now in
restaurants yeah Ted Cruz was doing that
to me at the universe you know did you
become more right-leaning since you're
from you're from Massachusetts right
raise that what were you rated I mean
it's it's you think of it as just a
solid blue always everywhere I was
molested by a guy in a pickup truck
himself that stance no I just I'm more
of a traditionalist I mean I'm just a
working-class Boston wasn't that you
know Massachusetts wasn't that liberal
when I was a kid I mean was just it was
just Kennedy nation it was it was
Kennedy nation but you know then you saw
clips of white kids throwing
then everybody got confused no I don't
know that's a good question but I just
because I don't think the ideology left
the right it's more about logic common
sense it is yeah and if you follow that
through your life you'll end up yeah
more right you'll you'll end up like
myself for myself or everyone in this
room so yeah yeah you got that to look
forward to feel good about your life
choices so we're gonna do it rebuttals
if it ever watch box probably not me
coming on a big watcher of I Hawkes
knows I love that shannon bream the
reason we're gonna rebut this video here
is not just because of the play count
but it's so America I think of how like
you just said have the left argues
particularly 2018 the first major
problem with this video it's about
sexual assault and it's actually about
why Kavanagh accusers can't remember
yeah and not only why they can't
remember but why they shouldn't be
expected to remember any details yeah so
we'll get into why this is exactly just
like the kid said in in the the change
my mind our views are so nuanced we
couldn't possibly be expected to
articulate them effectively so it can be
said the first major problem of this
video is it assumes that the assaults
happened and then works from that
premise beginning with going back to
Clarence Thomas he spoke about acts that
he had seen in pornographic films
involving such matters as women having
sex with animals and films on group sex
or rape scenes this is a clip from the
1991 hearing of Anita Hill isn't it a
law professor who blends one straight
night woman followed by a gay Latino
male it's a very odd contrast over the
course of three days Hill was bombarded
with questions meant to highlight
inconsistencies in her story you have
added during the course of your
testimony was a to new witnesses when
you talk to the FBI there was one
witness the witness did not say anything
to the FBI about the described size of
his penis the goal of these questions
wasn't an old white guy food pills
memory was faulty how reliable is your
testimony
on events that occurred 810 years ago
how sure can you expect this committee
to be on the accuracy of your statements
soon enough senators were suggesting
that hill might be imagining thing it's
funny they plate with like the horror
film background though all of us are
watching this going can you believe they
asked her how she knew it was accurate
yeah exactly can we be sure that what
she remembered is correct did happen to
me when I showed up in court first
speeding ticket the vet contested yeah
like how do you know how fast you're
going and it almost tripped me up for a
second like whoa whoop because I have a
speed tailing device in my car a little
bit of time to figure out the box
20 years later history is repeating
itself I can tell by your shirt history
repeating itself in a sense that what
the allegations against Thomas were a
completely baseless smear campaign it
was confirmed that it's pretty well
known that an even hill was lying am I
the only one who actually when I finally
found out what the Clarence Thomas thing
it was cocaine I'm like that's it he
sounds great I wanna party with Clarence
Thomas yes wouldn't you wouldn't you
want a clerk for him absolutely I mean I
put a pube on a birthday cake oh I
thought I was very funny did you see
Chris joke or drinking the coke I was
hoping somebody I need some caffeine
well here's a quarter coke of the Pele
blonde enjoy just Lindsey fingers like
the Grinch taking candy canes coming in
off range
he was great yeah golden room really all
of a sudden he grew a set I think is
another clip here from a gala do you
know what box this fixation on how well
a victim can remember exactly what
happened to them it's bull and experts
say is getting in the way of us take
incredible sexual assault allegations
serious okay
here's actually what they found out was
that Ford has zero case yeah okay so
Rachel Mitchell but really basic white
girl named easy to forget she wrote in
the legal context here's my bottom line
he said she said case is incredibly
difficult to prove but this case is even
weaker than dr. Ford identified than
that because dr. Freud identified other
witnesses to the event those witnesses
either refuted or allegations are failed
to corroborate them for the reason
discussed below I do not think that a
reasonable prosecutor would bring this
case based on the evidence before
committee nor do I believe that this
evidence is sufficient to satisfy the
preponderance of the evidence standard
this by the way would be in you know how
OJ was not guilty in a criminal but
guilty and civil this is the civil trial
standard yeah people who don't know
preponderance evidence just means to go
forward with a cake to go forward in a
trial just means it has to be more
likely that it happened then not
happened she's saying that isn't even
being met here yeah and and really the
big thing for me is that this it's more
about the system that we have instead of
the person right it's not about Kavanagh
and it's not about her it's about this
system that we have that says you're
innocent until proven guilty you can't
tell me that we just have to take any
witnesses for any crime their testimony
alone with no evidence whatsoever
especially like you just said where
there's three people that could
corroborate didn't sure I can I can tell
you that some of vice-president T see
you next clip ford admits that she can't
remember some important details like the
exact date of the party whose house it
was at or how she got there well notes
taken by Ford's therapist in 2012 also
state four boys were in the room during
the time of the assault but Ford says
there were two and says the discrepancy
was due to an error on the therapists
part those gaps and inconsistencies have
triggered a barrage of speculation about
whether Ford's memory can accurately be
trusted kind of details what you say who
is that David Cross David Cross was with
Biden plugs he saw the same guy he was
important is their details only changed
after they were challenged something
nobody talks about I would say but you
couldn't remember the exact day it'd be
one thing if she said I don't remember
exactly which day it happened the rest
day that week she couldn't remember the
year yeah big thing the where who but
here's something else she only checked
when she said was it this kind of floor
plan this is where it happened and
remember the hallway was small then it
became a little hole and I was it was a
narrow hallway then it became what we
were in a living room and it so the
floor plan changed once they said okay
we can narrow it down to these places
and look at the floor plans maybe it
wasn't that floor plan it was the
location changed until a second if
you're checking me up but maybe it
wasn't the location the witness has
changed once they said well we asked the
witnesses and they were in the hall and
maybe it wasn't those witnesses that's
what's important it's not that it
changed as she starts you know things
were hazy and it came back to her it
changed when she got caught lying or
provide
not lying providing incorrect
information yeah about the facts you
flew more miles and the Rolling Stones
did in the sixties I don't like planes
what are you kidding me she spent three
minutes on the ground the Charles Grodin
in Midnight Run believed a sham lying
yeah don't worry we already we got to
get in trouble for that one let's go I
didn't say anything oh I did last week
week I don't want to thank dr. Ford dr.
Christie you can see this focus on
memory especially on Fox News this is
nothing he's not sore when it happened
where it happened alleged victim does
not know the address a date the owner of
the house why places this is because Fox
said it we're not supposed to KITT
they're reporting facts yeah it's kind
of their job these things are true well
the problem I have with that is that
nobody else is reporting it that's the
highlight there no one else is talking
about it always you were going she had
three witnesses no she didn't know I
guess she didn't see the Rachel Maddow
Show the other night I thought you had
some good point there was no big
whatever right there in our necks yeah
if you can't if you can't hear that on
the internet you guys just like ribs
how's that you can kiss my grits there
you go I love how you put your hand on
your knee anyway it's like any more
bourbon in the house and I'm sitting
like Lindsey Graham it sent who've seen
the poodle anybody next clip we have
this expectation that for an allegation
to be credible the victim has to be able
to recall exactly what happened to them
in detail most of us think memory works
like a video camera but accurately
recording events we see in here so that
we can review them later so if a victim
can't remember certain details we view
them as suspicious okay we don't want
every single detail how about two about
one there was a house and there was a
staircase and I know there was a toilet
in the house and there must have been
hold on was it miss Porter he's telling
a campfire story
there was a very dark house and a
staircase that's a campfire story I
wasn't
right I remember some giggling these are
that was you
half a detail it's just a funny the
actors are just because you can't member
everything no she can remember nothing
yeah if someone says hey what did you
have for lunch today and I go you know I
think I had the guilty you don't tell
anyone but you know what I had for lunch
that day you just move on well I guess
we'll never know that's clear if we
weren't expecting that a victim should
be able to just replay a video and
describe it the same every time that's
not how the brain works and that's not
how the brain works for any kind of
trauma not just sexual assault in other
words we're holding trauma survivors to
a standard that most of them won't be
able to meet and when they fail that
standard when they forget something or
contradict themselves the punishment is
brutal oh you see guy just spent six
minutes making the case that these
victims memory is unreliable it might
all ii am I getting it am I getting this
right right now let's let's rewind the
clip really quickly a Washington Post
columnist even suggested that board
might have Kavanaugh confused with a
look-alike asking is there a Cavanaugh
doppelganger rich little rich little no
what did he I couldn't think of any
raped you while doing his Nixon you can
you can scratch that I don't even know
where I was going with that one
rich little oh my gosh and I remember I
was working on two hours sleep I got
bumped from a comedy tour for rich
little one point yeah did what oh I got
bumped on my tonight show sperm Elton
John he's signed an album for me but I
couldn't even go up and see him I didn't
really want to little yeah I wasn't
eager to meet him but yeah they're like
you know getting bumped for the guy and
he shows hey have you guys heard my
Reagan her
like oh my god this is look in 2007 of
when did he die whatever it was before
this rich little boy he's still alive
alive I'm doing an impression of a dead
guy a very good Manila Chris Downey
Senor little let me just make sure I
have this right you just did an entire
video Vox about rape victims and how
they can't keep major details straight
and then you're rolling your eyes about
the the mere idea the mere concept that
she might have mistaken her accuser okay
this is on the point of there is it this
is presenting an argument in a way where
it cannot actually face any kind of
logical scrutiny because you hold on a
second actually or her accounts are
completely inconsistent they go well
that's entirely consistent with what
might happen with rape survivor even law
second she actually made these claims
when we checked them out it turns out
this Jen they go well she but she can't
be if I didn't know what she's saying
check this I just think we she says
something you should take her at face
value and we should be free to declare
him guilty yeah hashtag believe all
women by the way I think it's hilarious
that they put her up there with Anita
Hill on that because it's been proven
like you said earlier that she was lying
are you saying by computing her up there
next to that picture that she's also
like this is really bad reporting all
the way around what did the Nero film
was that where he says lie ahora y ahora
and you know it that is from this boy's
life there you go nice I said it so you
didn't have to you guys quit today that
we shouldn't question or investigate
allegations of sexual assault an
investigation is exactly what
Cavanaugh's accusers are asking for but
as long as we expect trauma victims to
have crystal-clear memories of what
happens we're gonna keep finding reasons
to doubt them regardless of how credible
their allegations are no no okay I'm
sorry about that logic yeah I know I
know sorry sorry gay latino Vox got the
videos already dated a few days ago this
is a few days ago they want an
investigation now they're calling it a
sham core saying that the investigation
would shield Cavanaugh this is how
inconsistent the left is their arguments
become dated by the hour hours every
single person in this room isn't it the
same as when it started is your idea the
same yet seniors quarterback at all it's
it's at least three quarters the same is
exactly st. due process that's it
innocent until proven guilty I'm just
gonna forget by with a five scene satin
a letter for a months not asking for
investigation while the hearings went on
don't want an investigation they want a
circus and this is why I wanted to rebut
this video we have senator Ted Cruz
coming up after the break it's
emblematic of how the left argues it's
not just about the the guilty until
proven innocent its if they couldn't
possibly be burdened to prove their
argument first they what everything
based on the survivors memory instead of
the evidence center few questions
driver's memories to get the truth they
say that memory can't be relied upon and
then it's like this changed my mind said
boy in the jogger remember the guy who
was a jogger yeah it was like yeah I'm a
jogger I'm sure you can tell are you
talking about okay I possibly tell that
you're a jogger that's the kind of left
that in my life they see their views as
so nuanced and grad or even if they see
their views as nuanced and right they
present them to be so nuanced and so
great that they couldn't possibly be
expected to articulate them to you the
mass is properly things like innocent
until proven guilty now my view is
different from yours really what's your
view well it's nuanced things like
evidence well what kind of evidence is
presented on't believe in evidence well
what do you think needs to be presented
that's nuanced things that corroborating
witnesses all and she said three and
they directly refuted her story well I
don't agree with that
okay you tell me what it is that you
believe in it's a little too nuanced I
couldn't possibly be burdened with
articulating them to you or in this case
prove them hey there's an idea
all right up next we have senator Ted
Cruz this is Nick Nick dip calm go see
him when he's performing in your podcast
please sign up basically on to sign up
don't you Nick dip
this here is top it's too late for him
he'll be hanged from the gallows crucial
but you can prevent future Tom's from
facing a similar fate by joining in
louder with Crowder calm / multi-jointed
a louder with credit calm / Muttley
unless you want more innocent Blackman
[Music]
right very glad to have our next guests
I just look at a spangly microphone we
left at that horrible start at Ted Cruz
that's the right one right there there
are other there's so many ted cruz's
that seem official on the Twitter's at
senator Ted Cruz at Sen Ted Cruz for
just Ted Cruz at Ted Cruz's is the main
one that's the political one at Sen Ted
Cruz is official but Ted Cruz why don't
you just you know have like the people
who take up all the other titles you
have a couple of calls made I would
imagine you know it causes you some
problems you know like at Sen Ted Cruz
ish get rid of them it's I look they're
all sorts of crazy things on Twitter the
nuts thing is I read all the bad things
on Twitter why I don't know because it
gives you a sense of what's going on
Heidi thinks it's just that I'm a
masochist but I was gonna say that yeah
every time someone every nasty insult so
for every lefty out there let me see if
you actually have something clever and
funny yeah I'll like read it to the team
like if someone's like you know f you
it's like okay well that's very special
right you know a good insult that stings
is really funny those those are
hysterical by the way I've got to say I
saw a show you did recently of this
lefty who said he wanted a piece of you
that's a lot of them you have to narrow
it down
jeanny and hunted him down I didn't hunt
let's be careful with the language there
because next thing I was gonna blame me
for creating a map no no I dressed as a
genie and granted his wish
yes hysterical I was doubled over I was
driving somewhere in Texas watching it
on my phone and doubled over laughing
well thank you very much I appreciate it
but back to the insults it's true one
was I think a QB Garrett knows someone
insults me one time sits I'm like this
is about as terrible as that zit that
Crowder tried to clearly cover up and it
was true I had and I was like oh man
that's a beautiful burn it stings it's
worth it and we repost them but if it's
just vulgar and ain't it's not really
fun yeah okay well I'm glad to see these
easy you can appreciate let me look at
to see the sense of humor this side of
Ted Cruz so speaking much obviously this
is a race right now obviously for for
people who don't know there's you know
Senate is it is some it's important in
our government I would advise they go
check out Schoolhouse Rock let me ask
you this why is it even being discussed
as though it's within striking distance
with this O'Rourke character well it's a
crazy time the hard left they're really
angry they're filled with rage they're
filled with hatred for president Trump
sure and we're seeing that spill out
everywhere you look I mean we're saying
it
you know this this past week Heidi and I
were confronted by screaming protesters
having dinner in Washington and and
right they basically shut the restaurant
down by screaming and yelling and
surrounding us and we see that kind of
nastiness just growing and growing and
growing well that kind of energy it's
politically it's dangerous because what
it means is tens of millions of dollars
are flooding into the state of Texas
that if you're on the far left and you
can defeat one Republican in the country
who's on the ballot it'd be me yes and
and so they're flooding the state with
cash and and well if your goal is to
defeat an actual consistent conservative
Republican yeah yeah you know that they
would be going after you and that's what
that's what bothers me about this so
much I don't really think it's nearly as
close as the media is trying to cover it
but you're not gonna get a prime spot on
Ellen the same way it's amazing that
these people who would never pay
attention to this race are putting all
this momentum behind a guy just to put
them within you know I mean how close do
you really think this is do you think
it's as an example of Trump where it
won't even be close well the polls Texas
has been trending more perfect so when I
ran in 2012 I won the state by 16 points
right in 2016
Trump won by just over 8 points mm-hmm
that's the same margin he had in Ohio so
nobody thinks of Ohio as bright red
unshakably Republican I think that's
true of Texas too that right that we
have we got 28 million people we have a
ton of liberals we have a good ten
million liberals in the state of Texas
now conservatives outnumber them but you
know you know go down to Austin and and
you know Travis County is filled with as
left-wing people as you'll find anywhere
and and there are a lot of them and
right now you know anger is a dangerous
motivator right if you think about it on
the right in 2010 President Obama had
been elected he jammed through Obamacare
II jam through dodd-frank and a whole
lot of folks a whole lot of
conservatives and libertarians were
ticked off he was doing a lot of damage
to the country and we saw a tidal wave
election in 2010 I think we want
something like 70 seats and that's big
that kind of energy is dangerous in part
because it unifies you so folks on the
Left they may disagree on all sorts of
things are you a full-on socialist or
communist I mean they're having those
kind argument yes exactly yeah
or Marxist and I think the only
difference of that
when is a beard or the length thereof
yes look there's a queue but I'm not
gonna knock anyone for having a beard
but look the anger lets them all be
unified they can all agree the hate
Donald Trump right and so that keeps
them together the danger on the right if
you look at the centre-right coalition
conservatives libertarians independents
is 1 or 2 percent are miffed about one
thing and one or 2 percent or miffed
about something else right and we may
not be unified and I do think these
Cavanagh hearings may be changing I was
going to ask do you think that that
changes the whole landscape here really
in the last I would say the last week
because when it started out it was
hashtag me too was riding it off that
wave and now with the inconsistencies I
see a lot of people going you know what
they might be rolling this guy to give
an idea Clarence Thomas that incident is
what made Andrew Breitbart a
conservative he tuned in he said I tuned
on to watch this guy get his and I
finished watching it saying oh my god
this is a modern day lynching this was
Andrew Breitbart he said this Wow well
look I think last week was a circus that
was new lows for Washington yeah
and I do think there's a real difference
between how the two parties handled it
once the allegations broke I thought it
was important that we give dr. Ford and
an opportunity to tell her story that it
be fair and that she be treated with
respect
sure and I think that's what the
committee did I think she had an
opportunity to tell her story and she
was treated with respect I also thought
it was critical that that Judge
Cavanaugh be given an opportunity to
fend himself and that he be treated with
respect and that didn't happen right the
Senate Democrats they were so consumed
with with with partisan politics they
were so consumed with just nastiness
that they were willing to smear this guy
to smear him as family to just and the
hearing became a circus I mean there's
one after the other of theatrics you
know watching Democrats in High dungeon
that good god teenagers in high school
drink beer I know
I shocked by the way I know you have it
but sometimes I have up here on weekdays
not a rapist by the way it case there's
any any doubt and do you have a high
school yearbook I keep it hidden yeah
look really bad find me someone who as a
teenager didn't say something stoop
in their yearbook that that's part of
being a teenager right and and to see
this Inquisition on well what does beach
Ralph's club mean right well I don't
know have you ever like been to the
beach with a bunch of high school kids
it's not complicated to figure out well
I don't I don't know I can't figure it
out because I'd never touched a drop
because I was in Canada and it was a
rampant culture of alcoholism this is
actually true though I didn't drink at
all until later in life watch I'll be
cross-examined for this because in
Canada people drink so young that I had
friends who had serious problems with it
and then after college I'm very much
enjoyed craft beer once I learned it
wasn't almost and dry yes let me let me
ask you this at this point to all every
allegation was treated just as
legitimate as the first one do you think
that's kind of what ended up being the
nail in the coffin for Democrats was it
was okay Christine Ford is what sorted
then it was mr. Cavanaugh are you a gang
rapist I mean that was and it was so
clearly I don't want to say fraudulent
but there was no evidence whatsoever
that they reached too far look I I think
that's right I think a lot of the
American people looked at that and it
was it was obviously political theatrics
right I think we had an obligation and
listen to the testimony and assess it
fairly that's what I was trying to do
sure and and that's why I wanted to hear
from both of the witnesses and and at
the end of the day I thought both dr.
Ford and Judge Cavanaugh that they gave
powerful testimony they gave personal
personal and moving testimony our job
then is to assess what to do because
their their testimony conflicts right
and and in a court of law typically when
you've got conflicting testimony the way
you resolve that as you look to art
what's the corroborating evidence what
is the other evidence demonstrate in
terms of which story is accurate mm-hmm
in this instance dr. Ford identified
three fact when missus all three gave
statements to the Judiciary Committee
under penalty of perjury so if they were
lying they face five years in prison
right and all three not only did they
not corroborate the allegations but they
explicitly refuted and they said this
isn't true yeah that for me was
compelling that's why I voted yes we
didn't see any of the Democrats
assessing any of the evidence we didn't
see any of them weighing we didn't see
any of them seemingly concerned with
what was true they were on a searching I
saw a book her asking Brett Kavanaugh if
he ever drinks on weekdays and I will
tell you people who see this will go
okay all right this is where I get off
the train
let me ask you this how do you think
this relates finally we do have to light
I know you're busy you have to get to
the airport to this election I noticed I
watched the debates obviously not as
many people watch these debates as the
presidential debates but for people who
didn't watch it huge contrast you were
talking about policy how well Texas is
done yes in comparison to further left
states and your opponent would opine get
very emotional talk about how he's had a
DUI and talked about how everyone needs
to be given a second chance have you
noticed that he's doing obviously not
accusing anyone of rape but it's that
similar emotional grandstanding that's
the contrast that I see in this election
well look there's a lot of pattern on
the far left where they try to be they
try to manipulate people with emotion
and they avoid facts or logic or reason
if you look at every couple of weeks or
every couple of days rather we see a
media puff piece of bait O'Rourke and
he's it's all rainbows and puppies right
it's just oh look at his hair look at
his teeth you look at me get arrested
for burglary am I mistaken I I know the
DUI just I think it's burglary but not
but arrested okay go ahead I don't want
to put you in hum but he's got great
hair yes he does he he and and the media
is deliberately trying to keep it warm
and fuzzy and not focus on substance
that's actually what I thought the
debate was important because substance
matters I think Texans are smart and our
economy is booming I mean it is going
extremely well none of Californians
would have their way we'll keep on
moving I've known you know and my
approach is I'm gonna ignore the
personal attacks I'm not gonna do what
the Democrats did in the Cavanaugh
hearings and go into the gutter yeah I'm
gonna keep it focused on substance on
the issues and on substance and issues
his position is radical and it's bad for
Texas it is pretty radically left I'm
glad to hear you say it because a lot
times would say well okay there's I
think he's pretty radical it is
typically in a general election
Democrats pretend to run to the middle
right this guy is running to the left
Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren and
I'll say you know you've got a lot of
folks watching you who are libertarians
yeah if you're a libertarian at home
this guy is a big government status yeah
he wants the government in charge of
everything he wants full-on socialized
medicine so the government's in charge
of your doctor your health care he wants
government regulation he's he's voted in
favor of a $10 a barrel tax on every
barrel of oil in the state of Texas yeah
now our
economy millions of jobs in the state
depend on energy and and he's perfectly
happy to just hammer it by the way that
works out for every one of us who drives
ya to twenty four cents a gallon in
taxes that you'd pay but he watched
Deepwater Horizon once so he knows what
he's talking about
no he's to the left of Nina Pinta Santa
Maria Cortez I think that's important to
know here's what I always say to people
listen I know we gotta get going what I
always say to people is uh Texas no
state tax and a surplus for as many
years as I can count we've got it right
so go forward and vote it's at Ted Cruz
that's right one at ten at Ted Cruz and
then Ted Cruz org is the website and and
Freedom Works that that would be my
crook closing words look for young
people why would you want some unelected
bureaucrat in Washington running your
life you ought to be free to choose to
choose your education to choose your job
to choose your free speech ie the left
wants to censor what you say to control
your decisions to tell you you can only
agree with them I believe in the
Constitution and the Bill of Rights I
believe in freedom and I think that most
young people in Texas and across the
country do as well but he does have good
hair though you're here actually looking
bet you got a little bit of wave now a
little bit longer I dig it that's at Ted
Cruz we will wrap this up after thanks
so much for being your Center I preach
thanks and really to wish you the best
[Music]
hey there YouTube viewer many of you are
not yet members of mug Club at lot of
credit calm slash mug Club not only get
this wonderful hand etched mug and you
do it for a seven days free right now
you get the daily show every single day
I kveld Monday through Thursday but the
rest of the CR TV lineup including Mark
Levine Roman Millennial Gavin McGinnis
and at $69 annually for students
veterans or active military it's what
allows us to keep doing this you know
doing to change my mind doing videos
like that Eric Crowder confronts are the
bigger videos or we go on location or
undercover these things take days and
days to carry out and a lot of people
here who depend on my club because you
know we're not making enough of you to
anymore so if you want to support us if
you want to see the show continue a lot
of credit calm such mug club if you
can't be bothered to then you know um
probably be around that much longer
or you can also buy a Walther if you're
planning on buying a fight they're a
response they're our main sponsor to the
studios responded so MUC là-bas up but
Walter mug Club same thing it keeps us
going just don't give it to Susan
Wojcicki on now for the adventures of
the white privilege boy
[Music]
all right there now Timmy I know you're
a teenager but if I told you once I've
told you a thousand times you can't park
your vehicle faced into oncoming traffic
come on let's move well gee officer I'm
sure sorry can I just go back to my car
now I want you to follow my instructions
either get down on the ground or follow
me away from the vehicle what officer
can I just get my PCP now well you know
usually I'd say no but you can make it
quick come on get on out of here you
white rascal oh boy how about a free
base what people will they find
themselves in next stay tuned for next
week's installment of adventures of the
white privilege boys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's called the riptides with a
penchant for nipples askance family it's
very discriminating in its tastes why I
don't know why we hold our breath for
that I have no idea doesn't make a whole
lot of sense thank you so much to
senator Ted Cruz who's there really hope
that he just beats the ever love and tar
out of Oh work I won my spell debate is
it beta I say Beto is it's Beto but he
said we said bait not even his name yeah
but it's just so funny because he's
perfectly beta I'm amazing no one's
talked about this more beta O'Rourke
it's a it's a signal
who's your daddy by the way I love
senator Cruz he's a great guy but he's
he's very importantly as a lot of
handlers you're always like wait on a
second you're not gonna make like the
jokes that you do about label I'm like
no no don't worry you know what they're
thinking is like no [ __ ] no spot the
[ __ ] today right oh do please don't do
it we saw the young turks go after you
recently Oh Nick DiPaolo is here shoot
we have a great great week of shows here
next week
you know usually wanted to talk about
because I definitely do think that this
we always talk about how sort of toxic
politics has become and how angry people
are and I want to bring it back to the
fact there's nothing wrong with anger
there's nothing wrong with righteous
anger and I certainly think that being
falsely labeled a rapist would qualify
but let me take a step back when you
were a kid even look up to your dad
because he was sweet or because he had
nice clothes
your dad was worth its salt because he
felt safe if he had a good dad or even
more so I would say that it was
certainly like with my dad it's because
he made everyone around him feel safer
so this is actually something I'd like
to talk about with the dead both a
deadbeat man out there and the women who
tolerate deadbeat men first to all the
feminists who [ __ ] about toxic
masculinity and rape culture and that's
what they're shrieking about today let
me make this really simple
what should you look for in a man an
honest man with a backbone that's it
you want a man who you're going to reach
for when the wolves are at the door and
to the men we've talked about this a lot
that the in cells right the involuntary
celibates the professionally outraged
over alimony and child support payment
crowd sorry I'm not on board with you I
understand equality I understand people
being upset with feminists and how far
they've reached but this men's rights
crowd that sometimes just go
too far the other way you know what you
need to learn to be the person that your
woman's gonna want when wolves are at
the door now why is that symbolism so
important we've used this term on wolves
at the door you hear that a lot raised a
clue what why wolves at the door few
things one it's not meaning people at
the door meaning you are not one of them
there's a delineation it's an animal -
it's not Tigers at the door it's not
water moccasins those are really freaky
though if you see the water snakes and
they do with their head up but they
terrify me it's wolves and a big wolves
are pack animals
very seldom are they dangerous by
themselves but in the pack they become
ruthless and bold and killers and that's
we have to protect yourself against the
pack of wolves can come in the form of a
pitchfork mob the trial bit public
opinion the gossipers in your church the
gaggle of so-called friends who betray
you when you thought they wouldn't peer
pressure howl like hell it could
actually be a gang of rapists the pack
of wolves could be a gang of rapists but
this whole rape witch-hunt
it's a throwing away of due process
right now this is it's it's indicative
of a society with both men and women who
don't know what a man is supposed to be
and I know now the feminists are gonna
listen this is just as much for women as
it is for men it is more important for
society right now to know what a man
needs to be and that means not just for
himself but for his woman and for his
family
patriarchy okay let's go with it because
I as a Christian I'm gonna be the one
standing before the Lord accountable for
my actions and my house whether you
don't believe in it but okay
it proves to be the case pragmatically
even if you look at sentencing not all
men are rapists let's start with that
but all good men hate rapists all good
men all good men that I know would fight
to their very last breath to prevent an
innocent woman from being raped even
harden could deviate to you who get
hardened criminals and prisons the thing
that's so crazy to me
if you're a rapist and you go to prison
ironically you're getting raped which we
joke about in this fine and I'm not
saying I'm upset about that but because
of the double standard I think it's
funny but it's just it's it's it's it's
crazy to me that people actors that we
do not tolerate rape every man I know
hates rapist even bad criminals armed
robbers arsonists hate rapists but you
know what the
then you you want out there castrating
the rapists the men you cling to when
the wolves at the door they're never the
white knight modern male feminists who
travel in packs like the wolves those
men are cowards they don't respect women
they're just looking for an inn and I
saw this at the change my mind with the
guys walking in going well I think that
this made my friend cry you're just
trying to get laid man you didn't even
have a point of view you don't have any
beliefs how am I supposed to believe
that you're gonna stand up for anything
you don't even stand for anything
yourself you came up to this desk and
you said well I'm really not prepared
shut up and go home and learn to be
prepared because a man should be
prepared if you believe in anything this
isn't some false machismo bullcrap okay
I'm asking you women genuinely what kind
of a man do you want when the wolves are
at the door if you're at a party you're
uncomfortable with some douchebags
around there drinking too much you feel
a little vulnerable who do you want
there with you what kind of a man do you
reach for it does not to be that extreme
let's say your supposed best friend at
work betrayed you toss her a lot on with
the rest of the gaggle in the office and
they got you to be fired from your job
okay I'm just an I think of some example
it's not as Extreme as rape but rape is
on the mind everything is rape every
right these days Lyle Lyle and you know
it that's what's on the brain sorry but
okay let's just say you're in a
situation maybe many of you are in this
right now this is for the women out
there you have a friend but I hear this
story a lot I've heard it from I've had
it happen to me betray you you lost your
job you come home what kind of a man do
you want to reach for because that's
what matters and to the men out there
what kind of man are you
I understand this trials evoke a lot of
emotions right but I've seen a lot of
generalized negative talk about all
women I know how they sound when I say
this even though I think it's important
to note that someone like Ford is an
exception not the rule
so instead of saying all women are crazy
women suck what kind of a man are you
what kind of a woman are you going to
attract will it be a Christy Ford can
you say that you are the man the woman
who if you had to pick right if you
could pick the woman you love are you
the man in a roomful of guys that she'd
want by her side when the wolves are at
the door because that comes with a track
record that comes with a track record
that came that's not a sit down and
listen you
my friend cry but I'm not really
prepared for this that's a track rest
record a lifetime of honesty integrity
discipline no one just rolls the dice on
the squad leader and if you're not that
man you need to work on yourself because
the kind of woman you want she's not
going to want you so I do get a little
bit tired where I see guys passing the
buck going oh no I'm afraid to do it
anyone because look women are crazy no
no maybe you need to look at yourself -
yeah things can happen you can be
totally in the right and they can Brett
Kavanaugh you allegedly for all I think
he's probably did none of it that's just
my opinion at this point but what about
yourself are you the man that the woman
you would want would choose I guess the
point I'm trying to make here said it's
easy to make these assumptions with some
embargo Moo's lately that either all
women are crazy or all men are scumbags
and I know that's not true you know
that's not true but it's time that
really start working on showing that
women you need to have higher
expectations from your men period which
is not something that feminism has
taught feminism has let men off the hook
and many may have higher expectations of
yourself I also don't say you were raped
if you weren't raped
let me give an example of someone
because go back to it to anger when
people say anger is not a bad thing
there's righteous anger versus
douchebaggery Jesus knocked over the
temple hey would you call them tables
back then I don't know exactly
basically Jesus was pissed wow this is
apparent let's just say you're you
believe it's a parable let's let's just
say right that you don't you think you'd
are not sure if Jesus the man actually
exists okay the parable still believes
in a sinless man a perfect man who got
really pissed and threw over tables at
least caused property damage that's a
guy you want when the wolves are at the
door
guy I have a lot of respect for someone
who works in this show Johnny boy I've
told the story before I don't think I've
ever told it on air this is the true
story this is why he became my best
friend in high school and I'm great
enough to have him working on the show I
was talking with him right so you're me
and he's talking on the bus talking to
this is the front of the bus the camera
for this this is this is the back of the
bus he's talking with me I'm between the
camera and myself right now I hope I've
described us and we were talking
probably about jaws or something he want
he was obsessed with jaws and there's a
kid at the back of the bus throwing
pennies in there hitting him in the back
of it and he's talking he's getting a
little bit annoyed tells me hold on a
second I see him walk up to the back of
the bus this kid
his name was man says hey man could you
could you do me a favor could you stop
throwing that used to have thrown
pennies guy says yeah what are you gonna
do okay could you stop throwing pennies
please walks back up to me sits down and
share this is me right this is the front
you're the camera you're the front of
the bus people listening on audio you
need go watch this this is a visual okay
I'm creating a diagram just like the
score where they have the the tunneling
so goes back talking to me about 30
seconds later Thing Thing more pennies
hitting his head at this point my friend
Johnny boy stops looks back in other
words the signal I already asked you
about this and the kid does give looks
and give him one of these I think gave
him the finger nothing else was said we
continued talking and the pennies kept
going for about two minutes until all of
a sudden we hear the kid was getting off
it was his stop by the way they were in
the same grade there wasn't a size
discrepancy as the kids about to walk
off the bus
looking over grinning my friend Johnny
boy is talking he goes hold on one
second stops me stands up looks at him
and hits him as hard as I've ever seen a
human being get hit and the guy stumbled
off the bus and about thirty seconds
later because the bus sure was gonna
that's correct he was french-canadian he
kind of came to those yeah good offer my
stop who did see what happens well
here's the funny thing the next day
guess what he has to get back on that
bus he did not a word was spoken he
didn't go out looking for a fight he
wasn't a bully but there was nothing
wrong there that was righteous
indignation that was righteous anger and
guess what he's a friend of mine he's
the guy I would reach for as a buddy
when the wolves are at the door and
that's the kind of man you want to be to
your woman to your friends and if you're
a woman out there that's the kind of man
you want in your life and ironically
when we see this all the time even
though I believe you're strong
independent women like my wife is like
Johnny boy's wife is like my mother is
the only ones who are so weak that they
have to scream to be heard are the
liberal feminists are the people like
the Fords of the world are the people
like we sought to change my mind I think
so what do you think this is an
important part of this conversation it's
easy to get pissed with rape and no rape
and she's crazy and this
person's a [ __ ] and this person is a
jerk I think it's important to take this
opportunity to say okay what are the
roles that we have in society as men and
as women and I think even more important
is not just what roles do we have as men
and as women but what are you looking
for in a man and a woman and today we
just talked about men maybe next week
we'll talk about women but I'll have to
get a consultant see you next week
[Music]
you